I'm a director over the years of making
videos I've directed everything from my
mom to a dog to Will Smith now as a
director you want as many Tools in your
toolbox as you can get because acting is
very very hard you need to put yourself
in this imaginary headspace for getting
the world around you but not forgetting
it's so much that you miss your marks or
forget what the camera is all while
trying to remain vulnerable without
being self-conscious or embarrassed now
there's one tool that people have used
to fix these problems but in a
therapeutic setting or on the stage
that's hypnotism I've always thought
that hypnotism could make for a really
interesting directing tool but I've
never tried it until now
because we hired a hypnotist
the day we are joined by an actual
professional hypnotist Nader here hi hi
tonight thanks for coming of course my
pleasure thanks for having me I want you
to get as comfortable as possible put
your feet flat on the ground I'm trying
to create a subconscious action an
idiomotor response so go ahead and take
a deep breath through your nose
hold
and let it out
being a hypnotist means that you utilize
the Trans State it's a state that we're
all very familiar with we go into it
sometimes daily if you ever found
yourself staring at a point so fixated
that you couldn't look away well that's
hypnosis and I want you to feel your
hands are drawing closer and closer like
two ends of a magnet your hands drawing
even closer and closer do you feel like
being in this Trans State would be
beneficial to acting do you think it
would get a better performance out of
somebody absolutely really yeah hypnosis
naturally triggers the parasympathetic
nervous system the calming mechanism on
top of that it's very visual access is
very visual parts of your mind and as
long as they are visualizing the scene
hypnosis would be a perfect merge
between those two remember the hack
acting a little bit here sure yeah
potentially open your eyes and take a
look
isn't that amazing some of your hands
completely closed all right your hands
[Music]
all right so we've done the
suggestibility test and we've picked out
these four in particular to join us we
have two actors and two non-actors Nico
told me that I'm not an actor so I guess
that means that I'm not an actor I am an
actress I am not an actor I have acted
before I started when I was 10 years old
I joined sag-aftra I was in a couple
shows you guys know what Seven Minutes
in Heaven is someone spins the bottle
and whoever it lands on has to go in the
closet with them for seven minutes
acting class Muay Thai self tapes I'm
doing it all I would use hypnotism to
become a better actress for sure because
action class is expensive I have been
hypnotized before I would classify
myself as susceptible to hypnotism I
have never been hypnotized before
although my grandfather was a hypnotist
and I would beg him to hypnotize me
but he never did
[Music]
everybody here is prepared a monologue
we're going to perform it once we're
going to hypnotize them give them
Direction and have them perform it one
more time do we have a volunteer for who
wants to go first before every audition
I would throw up I don't deal with that
to the same degree but those original
feelings are rising again maybe we could
put a towel down all right so yeah
everyone and probably for the first time
everyone here is going to see my
vulnerable side so
let's do it
uh
I'm in love
totally
completely
fully in love with someone who I will
never have
and
it's so messy every day I hear her laugh
I smell her perfume
I feel her touch and it's torture
it's an absolute torture
and uh there's nothing I can do about it
you know
no matter what I try
just tearing me apart
[Applause]
I think inside there is a real actor in
there somewhere and I think this will be
my opportunity to show Nico that I'm a
real actor
let's do this
you see you wouldn't understand yet son
but your daddy's about to make a
transaction
a transaction that will change our lives
forever
that's why one day when you're about 17
years old I'll come up the steps and
you'll be sitting there cross-legged on
the floor with all the catalogs of all
the schools in America laid out right
there in front of you
no all the schools in the world and I'll
say
son
tell me what it is you decided it's your
17th birthday
where is it you'd like to go to school
where is it you want to go no
what is it you want to be
that's right you just say the words
[Music]
and I'll hand you the world
I have my monologue memorized so I'm not
worried about that
I'm worried about getting hypnotized
here we go
we got this
she doesn't listen to me
she just sits on the couch and watches
Jeopardy who bad-mouths my dad
it's the same speech I've been hearing
since he left
on and on and on and on
[Music]
and when he comes over to pick me up
she puts on lipstick
she doesn't wash her hair
she's wearing the same clothes for three
days
but she puts on lipstick
[Applause]
man I got so much talent here
I gotta follow that
if I were to ask the hypnotist for one
thing Daniel it would be to help me just
memorize these lines because me man
I can't remember these at all I don't
know if I've been able to memorize my
lines but I've got a little Canadian
secret here it's called the old uh
mystery took just do that
the lines fed in right here
I just uh
I never thought I'd be here
standing in this room
surrounded by all the memories
as a man I loved more than anything else
in the entire world
it's only been months
but I still feel him you know I can
still you know
just everything about him is still in
this room
foreign
yeah airpod trick didn't work
that's all you can do life's
unpredictable you know
Just Gonna Keep
on keeping on
every day for him
right here here I got the first sentence
and that was it
[Music]
when you start the hypnosis I think it'd
be great for each person before they're
hypnotized at least mentioned one or two
things the Nader that they want help
with now Jordan what would you like to
work on trusting myself and focus okay
let's start by just have you look right
at me you're gonna do another deep
breath in through your nose and hold it
okay
[Music]
now stare down at the hand resting on
the table and when you feel you have a
very good mental picture of that hand in
your mind's eye just simply allow your
eyes to close good and imagine that
right hand is growing lighter and
lighter just as light as a feather like
two ends of a magnet your head in your
hand getting closer and closer and as
soon as your hand touches your face when
you answer a deep hypnotic rest
and when you
perform that monologue just simply trust
yourself
and focus yeah I'm going to bring you
out of this state one two three four
five eyes open and want to work
you're great
well I didn't want to come back I know
right yeah it's very relaxing I'm just
floating in there dude I don't want to
come back I felt like I was still there
I was just so relaxed that I didn't want
to really move or you know use any part
of my body so I was just kind of like a
little limp thing for him to speak to go
ahead and uh start for us
someone that I see every day
[Music]
I
I see her smile I I smell her perfume
and I feel her touch
and uh
it's torture I really like Jordan
Allen's performances but honestly I
think he was right I think his first one
was the best
um I don't think the hypnotism helped
him the first one had the raw emotion
where the second one he was almost too
mellow the emotional spikes of like kept
paying of pain or a Pang of fear those
got smoothed out I didn't feel like I
could reach the depths I needed to it
was also smooth and like chill not in my
stomach that's just eating me from the
inside out and uh
it's not in my stomach that is eating
meat from the inside out
I was trying to dig deep and I just felt
like the sand just kept pouring back in
I couldn't get any deeper than I was oh
real well done hold on I got I gotta
make a couple notes real quick I would
like to put him into his chest's table
once more Channel Anthony Hopkins and
imagine
confessing to having murdered this
person he's talking about all right
relax got deep sleep now I want you to
bring to your mental attention
Anthony Hopkins in the Silence of the
Lambs one two three four five eyes open
in one week
I feel very high right now
Anthony Hopkins
in Silence of the Lambs
I don't know that I know that very well
I'm set if I'm giving somebody Direction
like that the actor gets a little scared
they're getting pushed out too far from
what they prepared and they like don't
want to get a bad performance they close
up in this situation it's like Jordan
Allen You're a murderer and you just
murdered this person and it's like I
don't get it but I'm going for it
I'm in love
I'm in love with someone that I will
never have
because she's promised to somebody else
[Music]
and I see her every day
I
smell her perfume I see her smile
and it's torture
it's absolute torture
and there's nothing I can do
no matter what I try
and it's
it's tearing me apart it is
it is eating me from the inside out
[Applause]
if I weren't in a hypnotized State and
Nico through that kind of direction of
me I would be asking a ton of questions
and be way less susceptible to just
going with the flow and trying something
and so in that sense being hypnotized it
did allow me to just put something out
there and weirdly be totally at peace if
it wasn't any good kind of got out of my
own way a little bit you're Jordan Allen
and you weren't sad Jordan Allen you
were this murderer so like tortured by
love that he did something about it it's
torture it's torture it's torture the
look on his face was it was creepy oh
here he is it makes me think that he
actually has murdered people before now
it's been ages all right Jake what would
you like to work on just a little bit of
confidence to be the character that I
need to be for this monologue the hand
drawn closer and closer to your face
thank you
and you're gonna find the confidence
to be that character one two three four
five
as open in wide awake
you see you wouldn't understand yet son
but your dad's about to make a
transaction
[Music]
a transaction that'll
change our lives forever once he had
been hypnotized you felt the physical
tells of acting Fall Away the clenched
hands the tightness that didn't exist in
the second one that was really cool
because an executive's life as hell yeah
because an executive's lap is Hell tell
you that much just tell me what it is
you want to be
and I'll hand you the world
that was great you crouched down you're
more active you're in it like clearly
your perception of what you needed to be
in the second one kind of went away and
you just did it okay I'm gonna have you
do it one more time
the time period of the 1920s just robbed
the bank
be justifying your actions to your son
because in your mind The end justifies
the means one two three four five eyes
open right away welcome back I have to
get some fancy for Ruth you know maybe a
Cadillac convertible you know something
for her to go around town and do a
shopping in yeah Jake's performance wow
he surprised me with the accent he'll
have all the great schools in America
laid right there on the floor yeah right
there this third one was the best one
you could see that he had let go of the
rest of us just tell me what it is you
want to be
and I'll hand you the world
he kept looking out the window as if the
police were actually after him oh but
it's so good it brings so many levels to
it because you actually don't know if
you're gonna make it to his 17th
birthday yeah you know what I mean like
with that extra oh that's so good you
know a director can tell you like hey do
it like this but you got that direction
this time under hypnosis
do you feel like that was more or less
effective versus just getting the
direction raw for me it felt more
effective yeah yeah how are you feeling
Jordan
you ready yeah okay this is interesting
I want you to just be a little more like
emotionally available if you could cry
all the time
roll's yours baby fingers really close
together good very good feel your
fingers wanting to separate and separate
and now fill your hand drawing closer to
your face I was immediately relaxed and
as soon as my fingers started moving
apart I'm like
eyes closed let everything go good
you'll be so comfortable with that
character connected to that character
one two three four five eyes open wide
awake
I do
you're great
listen to me she just wants to sit on
the couch and watch a Jeopardy and
badmouth my dad
it's the same speech I've been hearing
since he left the first performance I
was not able to cry but the second
performance I was being hypnotized
allowed me to put all of my guards down
I would absolutely bring Nader to my
next audition I swear one day I'm just
gonna go out and I'm never gonna come
back home I swear one day I'm just I am
just gonna go out and I'm never coming
back home after the hypnosis the second
performance Lord she really hit some
like emotional Peaks
tell her that she has secretly adopted a
puppy her mom finds out she'll be
furious but you can always be 100 honest
with a puppy
you're gonna Channel bringing home a dog
that your mother does not approve of but
you can trust that dog
a puppy
it's your puppy
on and on and on
whatever she puts on lipstick
she doesn't wash her hair
she's wearing the same clothes for three
days
when she puts on lipstick
[Music]
s where
one day I'm just gonna go out and never
come home
[Music]
you don't know how lucky you have it
you get to do whatever you want
[Music]
that was an interesting one it felt like
you were talking to a puppy yeah I
colored the scene that way it was really
interesting you can just do whatever you
want you can do whatever you want you
get to do whatever you want I was not
prepared for a dog so taking Direction
like that that changes up the whole
scene is very hard and I will say that
with being hypnotized and being able to
be more relaxed I was able to kind of
just roll with the punches a little
better how do you feel weird
I'm talking to a scum
what would you like to work on if
there's any way I could just bring up my
lines easier and deep sleep your lines
will just simply flow right out as a
point
good job
I just wish she was here so we could
make sense of it all
I don't think I remembered my life
[Applause]
it's a skill that I don't possess I'd
like you to tell him that he is a teddy
bear he's been sitting on the shelf
because the boy that owned him died
months ago and he's in my room abandoned
sleep you are a bear a teddy bear left
abandoned in the room and that child
that boy passed away
a few months ago
as open wide awake
I never thought I'd be here
sitting in this room
alone
surrounded by all the memories of him I
was like how do I be a teddy bear how do
I be a teddy bear but then I was like I
guess I'm just a teddy bear so it was
weird where I was like overthinking it
but then I couldn't overthink it
very strange experience it's just
unpredictable
just can't make sense of any of it
I just wish he was here still
[Music]
[Applause]
uh I think I was too focused on trying
to be a teddy bear I don't know
you haven't met you to change direction
it's tough to do man unless you like
unless you're in it what I realized was
Fender's performance is that hypnotism
cannot make you
memorize things like why do good things
happen to bad people good things happen
to good people or bad things happen to
good people but what it did do was allow
him the confidence to go in even though
he knew he didn't know the lines he was
like I'm just gonna still give it the
best I got I'm so stinking proud of
Fenner the fact that he did his first
monologue ever in front of everybody he
really went to a vulnerable place to do
that his last performance was the best I
was starting to see that teddy bear come
through Fender you're a teddy bear and I
was like okay so much of just directing
is trying to get that commitment it just
it just happened
you know I can't snap quite as you can
[Music]
so I feel like we learned today is that
hypnotism doesn't let you do something
that you can't already do it's not going
to somehow give you superhuman memory to
like know your lines but I feel like it
does enable you to do things that you do
have control over it just makes it
easier like we can calm ourselves down
you know if you put energy and effort
into it the hypnosis helps people do
that like it empowered themselves a
little bit more to do these things they
wanted to do but your body kind of gets
in the way a little bit and this kind of
let people push that aside the lowering
of the inhibitions the calming of the
nerves that's the guarantee of hypnosis
Outlaws I'm curious as to you watching
do you feel like the hypnosis helped the
performances kind of a subjective thing
and really can only judge by hearing
what people say so yeah leave us a
comment tell us your thoughts we'd love
to hear them wait wait wait Nico I think
you have to make a final decision
because somebody needs that trophy
behind you oh gosh
Jake
this trophy for the Hollywood best lover
is mine
it's keeping it for himself keep it for
myself I want to see who made the best
actor have you ever wondered how a video
like the one you just watched gets
edited here at Corridor well my name is
Jonah and I'm one of the editors here at
Corridor I actually made a one hour
click-by-click tutorial on how we set up
and manage our editing projects so if
you are an editor or interested in
editing go head over to Corridor
digital.com we have a bunch of different
tutorials focusing on different aspects
of the filmmaking process and there's
even a free trial for 15 days to get
access to all of that information for
free so head over to Corridor
digital.com and I'll see you there